Well, how is the princess
? [Music] Is she in a
good mood?
[Music] Dear
Aaah, is she wearing makeup? No, she's not wearing makeup. Her
soba is gone. Yes, she's
wearing makeup and it's gone. She's gone because she took off her makeup.  What you're
saying is strange. It's a contradiction. Oh, it's so troublesome. You
should have just
said it. Every day, I used dry viscous
makeup to make my freckles look like makeup. Up until now, people had seen
makeup.  Makeup isn't just
for looking pretty. I
want to know
why they do it to avoid being dragged into the back alleys. Even though it's a
flower town, they're hungry for women, and they're also hungry for money.  She's a small
child who is violent and has many sexually transmitted diseases, and if she was trained to be
skinny, she wouldn't be targeted so
often.So I don't know if she was taken in or not.Instead, she was
kidnapped, but her makeup was starting to wear off, and she was
judged to be something to sell.  That's right. It's too
bad. It doesn't really
matter because the management isn't very good. There's no difference between people who only buy illegal Kakumei and legal Kubota. I
don't think I'm right, but it goes without saying.  It's
not Hitoshi-sama's fault.
[Music] I'm
sorry. You're
unusually honest. It hurts. I see. I'll do it at the
venue.
[Music] It's a
man's show. I'm
jealous. I want it too. I can give it to you.
How should we divide it?
JA